بعد الصواريخ المضاده للدبابات والطائرات
بدون طيار والعربات المدرعه ومدافع قيصر
يدخل النزاع في اوكرانيا مرحله جديده من
حيث المساعدات الغربيه وهي تسليم الدبابات
الهجوميه تعتبر بريطانيا السباق في هذا
المسار بتعهدها بتسليم 14 من دباباتها
تشالنجر 2 المزوده بمدفع قوي ودقيق والتي
اثبتت فاعليتها في العراق على وجه الخصوص
البريطانيه هي اكثر تطورا من الدبابات
الروسيه اذ تم تحسينها عده مرات خلاف
للروس المحرك هو نظام السرعه والتصفيح
والانظمه البصريه هي اكثر فاعليا
خوفا من التصعيد مع روسيا لكن طول امد
الصراع على اوكرانيا تشدد على مطالبه
الغرب باسلحه اكثر تطورا من جهتها تقول
بولندا انها مستعده لارسال 14 دبابه من
طراز اليوبار اثنين المانيه الصنع لهذا
فهي بحاجه الى الضوء الاخضر من برلين لكن
بحسب صحيفه وستريد جورنال نقلا عن مسؤولين
المان فان المانيا لن تسمح لحلفائها
بارسال دبابات او انظمه خاصه من صنعها الى
اوكرانيا طالما لم تقم الولايات المتحده
بخطوه مماثله مع معداتها العسكريه وعادات
ستتطلب تدريبا خاصا من الجنود الاوكرانيين
على استخدامها وخاصه على كيفيه صيانتها
اما فرنسا فلم تحسن قرارها بعد فيما يتعلق
بارسال دباباتها الشهيره الكلاب هذا هو
سيستمع حلفاؤه اوكرانيا بقاعده رمشتاين في
المانيا يوم الجمعه لتعزيز تعبئه الغربيه
التي تثير في اي حال غضب موسكو المتواعد
بحرق الدبابات الغربيه